[Music]
tuesday is my favorite day of the week
feel like i've got a running start
everything's going to be great got some
scattered applause for people terrified
of being fired
happy tuesday everyone you know what's
happening when julie banderas made it
here in one piece
and so far child protective services
hasn't called
so how do you get my ankle bracelet off
oh yeah
keep it to yourself
so how do you know when something is
real like as real as my blue eyes or
tyrus's tattoos or julie's wine
consumption
you know when something is real when the
statistics match the stories when you
have mind-boggling increases in crime
from carjackings to murder to hate
crimes which are then coupled with
absolutely horrible stories that make
the statistics come alive
i've been on this planet for maybe 50
years after immigrating from california
and i've never seen anything like this
i know crime victims and i'm not just
talking about people who bought killme's
last book
now we've covered the stats and the
stories until we were blue in the face
so how could anyone deny them well it
turns out it's really easy if you have
help
we've been mapping this gleeful denial
since it started and it began where all
lies begin with cnn
yeah democratic cities are in chaos
right now is this what you want from joe
biden and they're going to take your
country away and they're taking down the
statues and crime is rising
oh my gosh it's so bad and they
defunding police it's like
yeah
shouldn't don lemon retract his eye
rolling since everything he just i
rolled happened
but if you listen to conservative media
well
you listen to conservative media you
would think that you know
entire cities are just you know enrolled
in fights and fires and whatever we went
out had a great dinner in new york city
tonight people actually walked up to us
and said thank you for i watch you every
night
what a lie
the only people watching don lemon every
night are in gitmo it's how they get
them to talk
no one watches don lemon by choice
now we played that clip a lot not just
for entertainment value but because we
knew where this was going it was the
beginning of the cover your ass not
covered the news strategy for they knew
they were responsible for the
anti-police pro-crime environment this
was the denial stage
but then when they saw crime could hurt
them politically they changed their tune
i think this is a blind spot
for democrats i think democrats are
ignoring this problem or hoping that it
will go away and it's not going to go
away joe biden may be afraid to do it
i'm not sure maybe he won't maybe he is
he's got to address it
the rioting has to stop
chris as you know and i know it's
showing up in the polling
it's showing up in focus groups it is
the only thing
right now
that is sticking
it's showing up in the polls well there
goes your great dinner in nyc i guess
politics affects your appetite not human
suffering but that was just the tip of
the scumburg
as all the data came out on crime we
continued to cover it because we cared
about our viewers and so cnn attacked
the messenger because they found
themselves on the wrong side
some examples of the banners on fox news
in the past few days you get the sense
that america's gone to hell declining
quality of life america as a apocalyptic
hellscape and yes there is a crime
problem but the way it's described on
fox you'd be afraid to leave your house
i kind of think of it as a instagram
filter brian you know you start with a
real image and then you take the filter
and you pump it up a thousand percent
and what you're left with is is
distorted it no longer reflects a
reality instagram filter that's going to
stay with me that's the perfect way to
describe it
oh man i wonder if it's an instagram
filter that's responsible for tripling
his chins
so people are dying
but it's fox headlines calling attention
to the deaths that really irk these
ghouls
the truth we report is kryptonite to
their false narrative and of course now
you see peppermint patty dismissing
crime because well she hates the
messenger too
on fox is janine pirro talking about
soft on crime consequences i mean what
what does that even mean right um so
there's an alternate universe on some
uh coverage what's scary about it is a
lot of people watch that
yeah well no no what's scary about it is
you and your boss and all the folks who
work for him are living in that
alternate universe and the victims that
you insult they live somewhere else
of course she asks what does that even
mean as if crime stats come out in latin
maybe we can get an expert to answer her
the system continues to fail us we are
not safe anymore
not even the members of the service i
know you were tired of these laws
especially the ones from the new d.a
maybe that'll jog jen's memory fact is
people are dying all over from violent
crime and jen dismisses it because it
didn't affect her pilates class
imagine doing that with victims of
police brutality or covid apparently
it's okay to mock crime victims because
those victims don't rate they aren't
romanticized so what alternative
universe do you live in
sadly the dangerous one that people like
saki's boss helped create but don't see
it's a place where women are pushed to
their deaths teens are murdered
businesses are ransacked until they
close and elderly asians are beaten
unconscious the media spent a year
telling us how people that walk through
the capital are worse than 9 11 while
completely ignoring all of that what an
unlucky universe crime victims live in
because unlike the media they don't have
armed security around the clock they
don't have personal chauffeurs safely
taking them to and from work or an
assistant who can run to the store and
get them suppositories thanks gabby
and yet the media claimed to be in
danger on january 6th
but no their universe is secure they
only get scared when they forget the
sunscreen at the hamptons so what
happens when you see bad things with
your very own eyes and you point it out
and people like saki laugh at you like
they just swallowed an ounce of magic
mushrooms
and the media safe behind their security
and anonymity laugh along like school
kids who just heard a knock knock joke
i guess pretending a massive increase in
murders is no big deal is literally the
best they can do and if bad things don't
affect them then they didn't happen at
all but it's a cover-up in plain sight
so we don't notice what caused the crime
wave which is them together the media's
disregard for rising crime and the
progressive embrace of policies that
rewarded the criminal created the crime
wave and now they're covering it up
now they need to change that narrative
they need to apply their radical
politics almost like
an instagram filter
sure this brutal murder of a young girl
looks bad but factor in that cash bail
discriminates against the poor and
there's prison overcrowding which is
cruel and there's covet in jail and
isn't the suspect really the victim did
you know he has dyslexia he's addicted
to meth and has gender dysmorphia he
thinks he's a woodland nymph
frankly isn't the criminal society
itself yes society is the culprit it's
the new way to blame the victim
it's a trick these hacks use to sleep
well at night also heavily medicated so
they can't hear the screams
[Applause]
there are more secrets in his mustache
than area 51 co-host of the five geraldo
rivera
she's like a home renovation
messy loud and completely plastered fox
news anchor julie bendera
she's disappointed more sponsors than
the olympics that's contributor count
and when he sneezes janisteen reports
gusty wins my massive sidekick in the
nwa's world television champion tyrus
[Music]
so julie i know you're too busy worrying
about being arrested to actually think
about crime
but try to concentrate oh you know i
know this is hard could these why
why is the media so far removed from
what people are experiencing every day i
mean the white house is so far removed
from what is experiencing today i mean
if she actually looked at what's
happening not in just washington dc but
in maryland in the in the state next
door how about that the highest crime
rate increase in the country um and as
far as living in an alternate universe i
do realize that marijuana is legal in
washington dc i didn't know that they
took gummies at the white house but
maybe that's the alternate universe
she's talking about because the actual
reality is that the crime rate in the
united states is horrible why because of
these liberal da's they are the reason
why they are allowing these thugs back
onto the streets the bail reform laws in
this country i hate to be a buzzkill
because i usually like to laugh on this
show
um oh and i and i also find that leaving
your sunscreen in the hamptons is also a
crisis it is it is but we've got dwayne
reeds on every other corner here so i'm
good yes yes yes you know what i would
like gummies to be at the white house
and that would explain a lot of biden's
like memory lapses is the fact that he's
doing gummies you know geraldo you've
been in journalism almost as long as
i've been
as long as you've been alive yes do you
think that the problem here is that the
press is less blue-collar than
white-collar if they were blue-collar
they would understand like cops i do and
i think that uh
you hit it when you said this doesn't
happen where they are so they don't see
it they don't see that that cop's wife
who is the most eloquent witness ever to
the job that the cops do and the
suffering of ordinary people in working
class and poor neighborhoods but uh you
know it's it's that's the problem when
you i have nothing against gensake i
don't know her she's kind of elegant uh
you know uh they there's there's all
those yuppies they don't i don't know if
they even use that expression anymore
young adult uh professionals but there's
a side of dc where there were 221
murders last year yeah so 221 murders
mostly black people killing other black
people so you know dc is a wonderful
place to live if you're a gensake or the
or the you know similar
right situation and i think that that's
the problem when you say crime crime
crime it's it's funny that
fox which is the
you know republican and mostly
rural or you know the other cities the
smaller cities we're the ones that bring
the attention to what's really happening
in urban america where all the democrats
are why do they still vote for the
people that they vote for when you have
this horror and the sons are being
killed and they remember when that the
two cops got killed what was that that
was a mother being beaten up by a a
junkie ex-con
on probation or probation uh with a a a
glock with a with an extended magazine
so they come to the scene they want to
say to save the mom who's getting beat
up by the the junky son and they get
shot they get killed a 22 year old 27
year old i just said and we we really
think this on the five that there's this
this was the bridge too far this was it
this is those two cops went down and now
that's gonna it's gonna be a sea shift
and people mocking uh you know the
suffering of uh of
urban america
their time has come yes and i wish that
they would be held accountable only
we're doing that cat i keep playing that
video over and over and over again do
you think part of the reason is the
messenger that it's fox and so when we
come out and we say something like we've
been followed like herald says and we've
been doing all this crime stuff that it
instinctively makes the people that
don't like fox take the most dumbest
stance which is pro crime because they
hate us
yeah absolutely
uh and i think that obviously jen sake
like any press secretary your entire job
is to just you know make the guy you
work for look good that's her job so you
have to say okay that's what she's
trying to do
but it doesn't really work anymore
because polling shows that people are
fed up with this people in you know
regular life who aren't working at the
white house see this all the time so you
kind of can't gaslight people out of it
anymore so even if she is trying to do
her job trying to make biden look the
best that she can make him look she's
gonna have to acknowledge this because
everybody already knows yeah yeah it's
there you know tyrus it's like the
democrats want us to be scared of so
many things like they want us to be
scared of climate change but when you
have like if you have friends of yours
who are mugged you're not supposed to be
frightened yeah i don't care if it's
raining or snowing if if my friends are
getting shot in the street i really
don't care what the weather is like
you know what is difficult for me when i
when i look at this whole situation
um
first of all
peppermint patty's american icon how
dare you i'm sorry yeah and you know
pasaki she doesn't talk to the american
people
[Music]
and
she talks to her bubble yeah stelter and
lemon they talk to their bubble because
when
lemon and what was that guy's name
mister get after it i missed that kid
cuomo cuomo thank you uh when they went
out to dinner in their bubble they had
they had a wonderful night yes because
that's their life yeah four blocks down
not so wonderful
so when you look at it they don't see
the things we see
so this instance with the the two young
officers being shot
i've compared it to a george floyd
moment what happened to george floyd the
entire country didn't matter what color
you were whatever was like that's not
right
those who didn't know now know
and my hope is is that
if this becomes
uh louis rivera
and i get he was 20 he was a baby you
know i'm saying it just and he was a man
of color where where are you black lives
matter
where are you right because you know
what oh my god why does your uniform
take away your skin color why does me
sitting here talking about being
conservative take away my skin color to
certain groups
when is someone gonna say that it
doesn't matter those are two brothers
down and whether they're brown but
whatever
where are you guys because it's the same
thing and there should be the same
outrage and it shouldn't just be his
wife it should be all of us and we
should be coming together to be like
this cannot stand i'll tell you where
black lives matter is in washington dc
the washington dc black lives matter
chapter came out and denounced us
calling these guys heroes yes that's
true that's where they are they're
denouncing heroes that were going to
save a black mother from her son that's
where they are black lives matters only
matters if it works in their agenda and
their pocketbook right they didn't speak
out about any of the 221 murders last
year in dc not one because the cop was
not involved victims who relied on them
to fight for them are still waiting for
help yeah exactly while they're buying
planes and it's not just them they're
part of manchester united it's not just
them
they they've joined the same groups as
all the other
woke
so-called liberal groups that are here
to help but they're not really here to
help they're just virtue signaling help
themselves all right
that was a very i need a shot holy crap
you know what i'm going to bring in
booze on the show i'm sorry uh i don't
know maybe come on check your glass jay
jay
lennon hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else